hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be taking a look at a game from
earlier in history than I think any
other game I've done on this series it
is a game between the one and only
Napoleon Bonaparte and the Turk of
course in this case the Turk is not a
actual Turkish chess player but instead
is a automaton those familiar with the
Turk probably now it was the
quote-unquote first chess playing
machine of course in reality it housed a
actual chess player a human chess player
in a cabinet kind of beneath the board
and it worked with some pretty
interesting machinery to hide the player
within keep him outta sight from the
spectators and the opponents and allowed
him to make moves using some some
machinery when pretend to be this
automaton it fooled a lot of people back
in the day and there was a quite a large
controversy kind of worldwide at some
point having to do with whether or not
this Turk was actually a chess playing
machine it played a few famous people
throughout history played some chess
grandmaster now grandmasters but some
famous chess players as well as this
game which we're gonna look at today
which was played with Napoleon Bonaparte
of course the famous Frenchman and so
we'll see how Napoleon fared against the
otamatone here today the game started
with one efore the Turk played 1e5
Napoleon an ambitious Queen f3 player
this might be an opening familiar to
some of you
scholastic players out there one two
Queen f3 or two Queen f3 kind of
signifies what Napoleon was intending
knight c6 then napoleon with impunity
plays Bishop c4 of course the idea here
being to checkmate black
however the Turk was no slouch it didn't
get to be a super famous chess playing
otamatone by falling for scholars made
every game so he simply developed or it
developed its piece with Knight f6 and
now white is already
of in a shaky looking position this
queen is really where this night should
go and because of this development for
why it's gonna be a little bit awkward
here and that that's why this opening
isn't really played at anything beyond
the the scholastic level with any sort
of regularity white does develop this
night though - II - well X simply
develops with Bishop c5 very natural
play getting the bishop outside the pawn
chain before playing d6 white now makes
a pretty substantial mistake of course
best is to play something like d3 to
develop this Bishop play something like
Knight c3 get castled even play
something like c3 to prepare a d4 push
but what Napoleon does is pretty anti
positional he plays a3 here
of course always better to develop your
pieces in the opening rather than play
you know not not so not so good wing
pawn moves like a three it's just a
waste of time black uses this time to
play d6 get this Bishop into the game
white goes ahead and gets castled but
now Bishop g4 develops with tempo on the
Queen this Queen comes to d3 and now
black plays the very nice Knight age 5
already aiming for some weak squares in
the white camp and you can really see
that White's lack of development is
going to be a huge problem for him for
him here
white plays the move h3 which is
actually a pretty good try black has to
take on e2 well it doesn't have to but
it's best for him and now you can drop
this Knight into the nice f4 square and
already this Queen is running out of
squares to go to it turns out Napoleon
probably should have put this Queen on
g4 it guards some squares around the
King notably it prevents this Queen from
entering the action which turns out to
be kind of critical black would probably
still play something like Queen f6
defend this pawn and get ready to castle
probably King's side and the game would
continue instead though Napoleon made a
pretty big mistake here
with Queen e1 and now after many many
moves black is simply winning but I'll
let you guys at home try and find the
best move here can you find
you check mate in eights I'll give you a
moment to pause the video at home ok
hopefully you got it it is of course
Queen g5 with unstoppable checkmate
coming on g2 nothing really to be done
for white here you can try to stall by
moving this pawn but of course now you
can take on h3 and with the open H file
it's it's going to be disaster instead
though the Turk did not play Queen g5
played another winning move instead
Knight d4 which is totally totally
winning for black but it's not forced
checkmate
now white tried Bishop b3 which is just
kind of a nonsense move it doesn't
really do anything and it's just losing
the game of course black has now many
many winning moves Queen g5 is probably
still the best instead though we see
Knight takes h3 check this pawn is
capturable but of course you end up
losing the Queen or this Knight is
capturing capturable but you end up
losing the Queen so instead we see a
king h2 and now this Queen comes into
the action and the end is near g3 was
White's try we see though Knight f3
check King g2 Knight take c1 with check
rook takes II won this Queen comes in to
g4 we see d3 but now simply Bishop takes
f2 the King side is collapsing and white
is down the Queen so without further ado
white plays dark h1 Queen takes g3 check
King f1 Bishop back to d4 threatening
checkmate
kingi two trying to escape queen g2
check King d1 black picks up this rook
gives another check King e1 now Knight
g1 is how black tries to give mate we
see Knight c3 trying to defend Bishop
takes pawn takes and checkmate Napoleon
is defeated by the Turk the otamatone
and of course in this game was not
actually played by an atomic on instead
being played by a chess player by the
name of Johann LJ LJ nobody knows how to
say
name for sure but he was one of the
first kind of serious chess players I
believe he actually published one of the
first chess manuals chess books was
written by him and for this game he was
hiding inside intimate on playing
Napoleon Bonaparte what a world
it was back in the 1800s well thank you
very much for joining me for this
episode of brain review my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time